[Musica]
[Applauso]
avevo pensato di iniziare questo Talk
dicendo
è arrivata l'intelligenza artificiale è
l'epoca è l'era dell'intelligenza
artificiale l'uomo diventerà inutile
Eppure mano a mano che si avvicinava
questa data
ho cominciato a vedere che le
informazioni telegiornali giornali ne
parlavano sempre meno era già finita la
novità era già finito live del momento
in realtà già non si parla Non si parla
più di intelligenza artificiale con lo
stesso con la stessa intensità fino a
qualche mese fa
ed ora ho avuto una riflessione ho
pensato che in realtà di epoche ne
abbiamo già viste tante già chi ha la
mia età c'era l'epoca di Mirko c'era
l'epoca del lettore mp3 c'era l'epoca
dell'iPhone dello smartphone poi di
WhatsApp di Instagram di Tik Tok
tutto ravvicinato tutto estremamente
complesso
l'epoche durano pochissimo quindi
probabilmente è il caso di chiamarla
L'epoca della compressione
eppure in tutti questi cambiamenti che
continuano ad avvicendarsi in poco tempo
in periodi estremamente ravvicinati c'è
una costante
sempre
e dall'essere umano siamo noi
l'unica costante che è sottoposta a una
riconcettualizzazione completa ogni
volta ogni volta che c'è una nuova epoca
ci vengono imposti dei nuovi standard
dobbiamo rispettare delle linee guida
dobbiamo avere un certo numero di
condivisioni dobbiamo avere un certo
numero di like dobbiamo apparire un
certo numero di volte in un Valzer di
possibilità e di limiti che viene
costantemente accorciato e allungato
quasi come se l'uomo arrivasse davvero
essere superfluo Ed è l'unica specie che
tra le sue potenzialità a quella di
rendersi inutile
questa potenzialità dell'essere umano è
l'argomento di oggi perché dobbiamo
puntare si dovrebbe puntare a un nuovo
tipo di essere umano che riuscisse ad
adattarsi al cambiamento in maniera
estremamente più veloce di quanto madre
biologia ci ha fornito in grado
ed è così parlando di potenzialità che
ci si avvicina al bioking
baiolaking è una disciplina appunto che
Coniuga Sapiens millenarie che vengono
da tanto lontano e le unisce a
conoscenze moderne di fisiologia di
anatomia di nutrizione di benessere e
alla tecnologia
e lo fa
nell'ottica di una filosofia che è il
transumanesimo cioè l'andare Oltre
l'uomo
il superare i limiti i confini
dell'essere umano per andare oltre
e lo fa attraverso questa figura questa
nuova figura che è la figura del
baioaker colui che si studia si analizza
cerca di comprendersi fa suo quella
aforisma che è conosci te stesso
cercando di misurarsi come ci è già
stato detto cercando di comprendere cosa
è realmente importante
andando a cercare di scoprire le uniche
limitazioni degli studi su larga scala e
cioè n = 1 n = 1 per chi fa ricerca
significa con un solo soggetto
normalmente insignificante ma siamo noi
ciò che funziona per noi ciò che fa bene
a noi
è colui che si studia Che prova che
cerca di comprendere le reazioni del suo
corpo all'ambiente esterno le comprende
attraverso dei dati misurabili
in un processo che non è ad aggiungere
non dobbiamo fare l'errore di pensare
che il baioacker sia colui che compra
costosi in innoli tecnologici solo per
diletto È un processo a sottrarre a
togliere a cercare di capire cos'è
realmente essenziale quali sono quelle
due o tre abitudini che realmente hanno
una gigantesca influenza sulle nostre
giornate senza fare tutto ciò che ci
viene detto in maniera cieca
esserci senza esserci era il rischio in
una realtà che è lisergicamente
mescolata con la realtà virtuale quando
mi approcciai a questo mondo all'inizio
mi batteva Paradossalmente subito in
quello che era l'ambito più estremo del
biohacking e cioè i grinders persone che
utilizzano la tecnologia
Fanno degli impianti nel proprio corpo
per potenziarsi per avere dei sensi
maggiori per avere dei sensi nuovi per
misurare dei dati 24 ore su 24 anch'io
nel mio piccolo è un piccolo esperimento
con un chip sottopelle in grado di farmi
percepire i campi magnetici intorno a me
all'inizio mi sentivo onnipotente avevo
un senso in più più di quanto Madre
Natura mi aveva dato nel progetto
originale
dopo qualche giorno divenne quasi
fastidioso e mi resi conto che
effettivamente questa cosa non aveva uno
scopo reale non mi aveva reso migliore
in quanto essere umano non mi aveva dato
nulla non mi aveva insegnato nulla
Questo è il rischio ed è la domanda che
spero già tutti si possono fare
sul cosa è necessario e soprattutto
in un mondo in cui attualmente è
facilissimo misurare la qualità del
sonno l'effetto che ha l'alimentazione
sul nostro corpo l'effetto che
l'alimentazione sul sonno misurare il
nostro DNA e sapere a quali malattie
siamo predisposti
meditare ogni mattina esporci al freddo
quotidianamente fare dei Digiuni
scrivere tutte le nostre emozioni ogni
sera fare delle liste di produttività
dividere il tempo in pomodoro
da 25 minuti
tecniche di produttività per essere
sempre di più per andare sempre più
veloci in epoche di frenesia perché
dovremmo farlo
Al momento la religione si fonde con la
spiritualità che a sua volta a sua volta
si fonde con la pubblicità col marketing
e con le ADV su Facebook il bioking al
momento si è fatto oggetto schiavo non è
più un Messaggero per Una terra promessa
ma è un prodotto che viene venduto su
Instagram
perché dovrei misurare il mio sonno
perché dovrei respirare col diaframma
perché dovrei stare attento
all'alimentazione utilizzare più grassi
perché dovrei scrivere le mie emozioni
In definitiva per cercare me stesso per
essere non per apparire per cercare di
comprendere Come posso essere più
performante Sì in un'epoca che lo
richiede tutti i lavori lo richiedono
senza perdere l'ancoraggio alla realtà
col mio lato spirituale utilizzando in
questo senso la tecnologia per espandere
i limiti esterni ma soprattutto quelli
interni seguendo una linea guida
che cerca di non farmi di staccare
dall'essere presente dall'essere
consapevole parole che avete già sentito
oggi che sono quanto mai importanti nel
mio discorso
in questo senso il baioager è colui che
cerca di rompere queste catene quello
che gli viene imposto dall'esterno colui
che cerca appunto l'analisi la
performance colui che cerca di essere
efficace efficiente Ma che cerca anche
di non perdere il suo lato interiore
è un versukender un cercatore come
diceva Hermann Hesse guidato da dei
Principi guidato da uno scopo guidato da
un obiettivo
Ulisse e prometto ci hanno mostrato
storicamente che fine si fa se si cerca
una conoscenza solo per curiosità la
curiosità solo per la curiosità e
nozionismo è abbastanza inutile non ci
porta un cambiamento non ci porta ad
essere diversi non ci fa fare niente di
più di quella che è la nostra base
per un transumanesimo che adesso nelle
parole di Tim Cannon uno dei più grandi
filosofi del bioacking è un
transumanesimo coerente la coerenza
cardiaca è la scientificizzazione del
Nirvana della pace dei sensi un concetto
moderno anzi in realtà è un concetto
antico attualizzato
il transumanesimo corrente è per nuovi
esseri umani che cercano semplicemente
di adattarsi facendo proprio quello
spirito di sopravvivenza che era insito
nella nostra natura utilizzando Ripeto
la tecnologia e non essendone schiavi
cercando di seguire il proprio paradigma
e non sottostare a quello che viene
dall'esterno non per me era ribellione
non per capriccio ma semplicemente
perché capiamo e Comprendiamo cosa ci fa
stare bene perché lo possiamo misurare
In definitiva
lo scopo è semplicemente quello di
essere
stavolta di nuovo totalmente Grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]